so what's going on is that Rishi sunak
has had his first proper reshuffle just
over 100 days into his time as prime
minister now in some ways it was thrust
upon him by the fact he had to Satin at
him so how we as conservative party
chair eight days ago you remember that
early Sunday morning sacking uh thanking
him for him service after the
allegations over Nadim zahari's tax
Affairs and uh what was going on in
terms of what Nadeem Tahari was telling
permanent secretaries while he was
chancelloring in other jobs so Nadine's
Harley was out and Richard has really
taken his time to have a bit of a
broader look at the changes that he's
wanted to make and and he's actually
made a series of what what are in effect
quite under the Bonnet changes to the
way his government is going to work ways
in which it interacts in particular with
business so if there was a problem over
here with the conservative party
chairman he's actually used it to solve
a whole series of problems that he
thinks exists over here to do with
business and energy and digital strategy
and stuff like that so what he's done is
he's remolded Whitehall in his own image
to basically to allow him to have
greater flexibility on things that he
thinks need more attention so at the
heart of today's reshuffle has been the
decision to take it break up the
business department which uh previously
underground chapter did all sorts of
things but also as well as dealing
specifically with business also had a
focus on energy policy and climate
policy and also was detached from some
things to do with digital strategy so
he's he's as it were sort of moved all
of those things around so he has created
a new department for energy security and
Net Zero so that's the first big new
department that he's created and that
has Grant chaps the TV regular uh former
uh conservative party chair former
business secretary under Rishi sunak uh
big uh transport secretary for many
years under Boris Johnson big player uh
big beast around the cabinet table so
Grant chaps takes that energy and
climate change brief with a new
department for energy secure 30 and Net
Zero and then what they do is they leave
the business department and wrap in the
trade department so if you remember
there was a department for international
trade the Secretary of State uh first it
was Liz trust and it was uh Andrew Ellen
would go around the world trying to
strike trade deals uh Richardson has
decided that it's a bit of a nonsense to
have that separate uh separated out from
the business department since many of
the decisions that the trade secretary
has to make impact the business
secretary as well that's a long-running
tension inside Whitehall he's decided
that tension must end that division must
end so he has brought together the trade
brief together with the business brief
and given that to kemi badenok who until
this morning was the trade secretary was
meant to be going on a mission uh to
Rome we believe uh and she will now
oversee both business and trade there
she is you can see her on her screens
often thought to be uh in the event that
there's yet another leadership contest
one of the Front Runners so she she is
another newish very big beast around the
camp table then the next thing he has
done is he has separated out from the
business department all of the sort of
science briefs and is now putting that
together with the digital uh elements
that were previously in the culture
Department Whitehall slightly messy in
the way that it cut the cuddle these
things up so what Richardson is trying
to do is bring together science
Innovation and digital strategy in one
place and Michelle donalan who was
culture secretary is now going to be in
charge of that so think of that as being
in charge of things like online harms
bill I think that will sit within that
government Department the science
strategy uh how do you boost Innovation
some overlap there with the new business
department but I think science
Innovation and Technology this was one
of the big ideas that was championed by
William Hague Lord Haig who basically is
one of Rishi sunax binters uh Richardson
inherited the Richmond in Yorkshire seat
from William Hague he's been championing
for some kind of Science and digital
mashup within Whitehall that's what's
been delivered this morning so that
leads to vacancy the only new cabinet
minister right now is uh Lucy Fraser I
think she was the uh one of the housing
ministers in the housing department she
will now join the cabinet table she will
be Secretary of State for culture media
and Sport so that's taking the culture
uh brief to what it was back five years
ago so dcms culture media and Sport
losing the digital bit uh so essentially
at a department focused on the Arts and
Sport uh that reorganization has meant
some policy uh has been as it were
delayed we've got uh I think uh various
elements uh that sit sit in there that
haven't yet been announced that were
expected quite recently so Whitehall
reorganizations having something of a
delay and then the final big change
is Greg hands is going to replace Nadim
zahawi as the conservative party chair
uh Greg Hamza Hammersmith mp uh he's
been a veteran of the Cameron government
and subsequently uh he will now take to
the airwaves to defend uh the government
uh and uh basically play a leading role
championing it so a big role for a
London MP it's interesting that they've
gone for a London MP as conservative
party chair where so much of the
Battleground is outside of uh of the
capital uh at the next general election
so what is it all amount to what's the
big picture here well what it shows is
that Richards unite still thinks that
there is quite a lot of as it were
technocratic small uh decisions under
the Bonnet decisions needed to get his
government in uh fine working order in
order to get policies in place decisions
made and improve things ahead of the
next election a lot of this uh will in
headline terms today not be that
important for the way that the public
deal with government but quite important
behind the scene means in order to try
and get give better focus on key things
like digital policy energy policy and to
stop that separation between business
and international trade deals but Jane
there's a problem which is this is
involving a lot of Whitehall civil
servants and structures being moved
around and messed around and that is
going to mean there's an awful lot of
delay in terms of just getting people in
New departments in new seats in new
reporting structures it's basically gum
up government for a little bit because
if you if you move around parts of
Whitehall in order to do a as it were a
sort of government Machinery of
government change that does actually
slow the uh slow Effectiveness down it
does make it a little bit harder forget
to get things done uh as civil servants
and ministers get used to their new
brief so there might not be
instantaneous benefits from this uh
Whitehall shake up at warmth because the
complexity of moving all these bits of
Whitehall around uh and creating new
structures but Rishi soon thinks that
he's got the time to do it and it'll
deliver the results so showing that he's
still got his very much his hand on the
technocratic tiller when it comes to uh
to reshaping his government uh these are
changes that he might have uh done uh
earlier uh but when he became in uh when
he came in in November just over 100
days ago as prime minister he perhaps
felt he had to keep things broadly the
same because the situation that Liz
trust Left Behind was so as it were
unstable that he needed to keep the
structures in place this is the this is
the blueprint for the government that he
wants to run uh familiar faces in the
main cabinet ministers in the main
taking up the new jobs and Greg hands uh
the media Savvy face now the new
conservative party chairman